Buonasera
a me è stato chiesto di presentare il
progetto di raccontare il progetto che
abbiamo realizzato che abbiamo iniziato
a realizzare due anni fa a Ferrara di
chi da organic Forrest
mi è stato chiesto da un gruppo di
ragazzi che non conoscevo che ho
conosciuto ieri sera
conoscevo telefonicamente Un tal
Gregorio col quale ci siano
messaggiati quest'estate
ho conosciuto un gruppo di ragazzi ieri
sera che ci hanno offerto un
aperitivo qui in centro a Ferrara
e poi quando sono andato a casa e mi
hanno dato una lettera andato a tutti
noi una lettera una busta ha detto Leggi
la prima di andare a letto
e io l'ho fatto così l'ho tenuta in
Italia ero curioso e l'avevo un po'
aperto Praticamente
sono seduto l'ho letta
e mi sono detto ma guarda questi qua
20 non so 20 25 ragazzi tutti i giovani
che lavorano un anno
per dare la possibilità delle ad altre
persone no loro stessi ad altre persone
di raccontare delle cose raccontare
delle iniziative dei sogni tutto quello
che poi fino adesso avete sentito
è una roba che mi ha non la o meglio la
Grosseto a parlare di Tex però non
l'avevo mai non avrei avuto modo di
approfondire seriamente
e vi giuro che ci ho pensato tanto ieri
sera dicendo Ma è una cosa che non può
voi la conoscevate già siete qui quindi
probabilmente non era la prima edizione
qui partecipate però non puoi non puoi
rimanere così
isolata
perché c'è un pregiudizio nei confronti
oggettivo che conosciamo tutti Conoscete
tutti nei confronti dei giovani cioè
leggiamo solo notizie negative e
situazioni ambigue rumori botte eccetera
e poco si parla invece di altre
situazioni
e poi ho fatto fatica a dormire ieri
sera perché
perché mi è venuto in mente una cosa
che prima di raccontarvi di chida ho
bisogno di raccontare a voi o meglio Ho
bisogno di contare due tre cose a voi
per spiegare meglio a cosa si arriva
Cosa serve per arrivare ad una
iniziativa di questo tipo
bello brutta che sia comunque
un'iniziativa concreta
e mi è venuto in mente una cena che ho
fatto che ho avuto
tra gennaio febbraio del 2017 a Roma un
ristorante
del centro ed ero vicino con Paolo
Villaggio
Paolo Villaggio Era accompagnato da un
ragazzo e con me c'era un amico Un amico
storico con cui ho lavorato negli anni
Paolo Villaggio era già 120 kg aveva dei
problemi seri di salute o teoria già 84
85 anni e aveva una grossa tunica un
caftano lo portava negli ultimi anni
Anche perché era veramente tanto grosso
e quindi si trova più a suo agio
e avevo letto qualcosa non avevo letto
il libro perché ho letto delle delle
alcuni articoli su su l'ultimo libro che
aveva scritto dove diceva che tutti i
vecchi sono degli stronzi
e mi incuriosiva sta cosa perché poi non
avendo più un anch'io vent'anni mi
avvicinavo Mi sto avvicinando diciamo
maestro io lo chiamavo maestro che lo
vedevo con questa tunica gigantesca
Bianca bello dico ma perché tutti i
vecchi sono degli stronzi perché fa noi
i vecchi Siamo degli stronzi Siamo degli
egoisti pensiamo alla nostra pensione
Diciamo che siamo dalla parte dei
ragazzi però se ci tolgono qualcosa ci
ribelliamo siamo strutturati organizzati
abbiamo paura di morire siamo invidiosi
tutta una roba di cose negative
Diventerà uno stronzo anche lei
io è sicuro un po' meno degli altri
coraggio sta cosa perché perché mi sta
ascoltando e quindi il fatto che mi
ascolta probabilmente la mette sulla
strada buona di non essere proprio
stronza del tutto
dico sta cosa perché l'ho connesso un
po' al pensiero di ieri sera di questi
ragazzi che si danno così tanto da fare
per noi per fare raccontare le nostre
cose e questa
questo tilt questa
non incapacità questa non volontà di
riuscire a connettere queste generazioni
a me fa imbestialire uno perché ho
sempre vissuto in mezzo ai giovani le
attività che ho fatto sono diventato
fortunatamente circondato dai giovani ho
due figlie e quindi un po' di
sensibilità che ne dica il grande Paolo
Villaggio
mi è rimasta Questa è una roba che lo
connesse ieri sera poi in questi anni
prima di arrivare alla organizzazione
diciamo di questa iniziativa di kiddha
abbiamo avuto io e mia moglie che
abbiamo fondato questa questa società
mia moglie Silvia che alla quale robo
spesso i pensieri
le idee poi le faccio mie le traduco
e di quelle sono sempre grato
abbiamo fatto questa cosa Dopo aver
fatto delle riflessioni cioè una vita
sempre in giro abbiamo girato
dappertutto Ferrara abbiamo la casa non
ci stavamo mai
diverse esperienze
imprenditoriali manageriali
però ci siamo posti un problema per la
verità me la porto lei mi ha detto ma il
giorno in cui con quello che sta
succedendo con i casini negativi che mi
ha preceduto
ha spiegato ampiamente cosa stiamo
facendo noi
cosa diremo quando uno dei nostri figli
ci dirà Ma Ok tu avevi capito che era un
casino che sta mandando in contro una
serie di situazioni eccetera Cosa avete
fatto come come avete reagito E allora
questo è stato un pensiero un altro
pensiero era il fatto che comunque a
casa da anni la plastica non c'è o
meglio non sempre la plastica diciamo
nelle circostanze in cui c'erano i
bambini facevano i compleanni così mi
trovo sempre i piatti di bambù di altre
di altri prodotti altre cose forchette
tutte ste robe e ho detto Vabbè ecco
tutto sto bambù prima o poi ma parlo di
10 anni fa dico prima o poi dico mi
troverò anche la carta igienica di bambù
Guarda che esiste già anche migliore
delle altre quindi mi do un dato ehm il
18% dei boschi di tutto il mondo che
vengono tagliati o meglio l'utilizzo del
del del taglio del 18% dei morti che
servono per per uso diciamo ehm attivo
va a finire di carta igienica ne
parliamo quasi del 20% dei Boschi
tagliati che è carta igienica quindi
forse
quella roba del della carta igienica col
bambù poteva essere poteva essere presa
per tempo
Insomma arriviamo A
dopo queste riflessioni dopo aver
discusso per tanto tempo ragionato tanto
per tanto tempo che quando eravamo
quando ero più giovane quando avevo
l'età dei ragazzi del Telex il futuro io
lo vedevo noi lo vedevamo come come una
promessa non come una minaccia mentre
Oggi si è invertita questa cosa spesso
si è invertita questa cosa e abbiamo
detto Vabbè dobbiamo fare qualcosa di
concreto abbiamo deciso di fare questo
investimento Eh la prima cosa che
abbiamo fatto abbiamo cercato sostegno
all'idea di sostenibilità e mi sono
rivolto un po' di non faccio i nomi ma
comunque fidatevi Uh ci sono stati
questi incontro a una testimonial da
qualche parte la mia la mia
commercialista che viene con me al primo
incontro che è diventata poi la mia
badante perché è sempre lì perché ha
paura che spendo troppo Ogni volta che
voglio comprare una roba mi mi rompe
Cioè ti fa vedere i compiti
un'ossessione però fa bene Fa bene il
suo lavoro Gabriele straordinaria
andiamo a questo primo incontro e
presento questa cosa dico Guardate vengo
da un altro mondo sì la conosciamo mi
dicono ho fatto il manager ho fatto
l'imprenditore ho fatto delle cose
concrete voglio fare sta roba qua voglio
mettere in piedi un'azienda agricola che
sia biologica che sia Green dove ci sia
dove voglio piantare 6 ettari di bambù
gli altri sei et le aziende di 12 gli
altri sei ettari metteremo delle altre
cose della paulonia vi ha messo abbiamo
un frutteto dove non usiamo diserbanti
non c'è chimica nella parte in tutta
l'altra parte a parte il frutteto che
c'erano un pochino abbiamo messo le api
abbiamo piantato sei ettari di trifoglio
nano per dare alimentazione alle api nel
periodo nel periodo in cui hanno meno
possibilità di di di di avere i fiori a
disposizione ehm la camomilla selvatica
le ortiche i fagioli rari tutta una
serie di robe il mais biologico per dare
alle sempre fare delle uova sane tutte
queste robe qui
mi fa parlare a 25 30 minuti dice Guardi
Fabio il biologico non ci credo
andiamo fuori però viviamo una mano cioè
nel senso che
avete bisogno dei conti fare Se avete
dei dipendenti le cose tecniche ci sono
però biologico non ci credo andiamo
fuori la mia badante e la guardi questa
mica capito niente Vado da un altro Cioè
vado da solo perché dico stavolta dico
non posso portarlo in un'altra
situazione alzo il livello e
racconto la stessa cosa La stessa storia
tanto Vi ho già raccontato un po' come
l'azienda e questo mi dice il bambù
per me la nutria delle piante
la nutria delle piante
perché Perché è invasivo dico per
fortuna che è invasivo Cioè è anche un
amico soprattutto che conosco io Ma
scusa un attimo C'è una velocità abbiamo
stiamo vivendo una velocità della crisi
climatica pazzesca non riusciamo a
rincorrere i problemi eccetera e noi non
possiamo beneficiare tra virgolette di
alcuni prodotti che possono avere una
crescita velocissima una capacità
invasiva e che in cinque anni per avere
un bosco alto 20 metri e che per ogni
metro quadro vengono su tre piante
vengono chiamate gli alberi perché
quando sono andato in regione ha detto
voglio fare un bosco Ma han fatto un
mazzo della Madonna Perché no È un'erba
Ok è un erba però è la grande così va su
20 metri cioè Palmi le narbur cioè
perché c'è la c'è la lobby dei Boschi
Cioè ci giuro c'è la lobby del legname
cioè la lobby dappertutto è normale che
ci siano delle organizzazioni
strutturate che faccio gli interessi
loro associati ma ok È un'erba un erba
grande e dico che però ogni tanto lo
farà 40 tonnellate di legno dura 120
anni ogni anno dal quinto anno in avanti
poiché puoi tagliarne il 20% e ti
ricresce in 5 anni quindi tu hai
instabile un bosco per 120 anni che
superano noi perché non ci saremo più ma
lui c'è va bene e non è un bosco Ok non
è un bosco è un un erbola una roba
strana che però a me sembra un bosco
insomma per fortuna non è tutto negativo
perché poi
La Stampa se ne interessate è venuta
anche la RAI Cioè ha avuto una certa
risonanza questa cosa è venuto il
sindaco è venuto l'assessore Balboni
all'ambiente che stanno facendo anche un
bel lavoro e un professore Maggi è
venuto il sensore Calvano della regione
Emilia Romagna è un professore Priolo
del sempre all'ambiente dell'Emilia
Romagna e
questo sostegno non sono andato a
chiedere i soldi all'associazione è
stata la promessa non ho bisogno di
soldi ho bisogno di sostegno ho bisogno
di capire se lavoro dentro un humus che
mi consenta di sentirmi ehm a mio agio
nel fare questa cosa l'ho trovato nella
parte politica e poi da un sacco di
gente che poi è venuta veramente
tantissime persone tutte di un'età tra i
25 e i 40 anni 45 anni quella fascia lì
è stata colpita da matti da questa da
questa iniziativa Quindi anche in questo
caso diciamo abbiamo trovato l'energia
quella che ci serve quella che che ci
stimola perché è vero che è un'attività
imprenditoriale però è anche vero che
nell'età impatto di investimento molto
pesante Soprattutto soprattutto i primi
anni abbiamo una pianta io non ho solo
il bambù non voglio non penso solo a
bambù però oggi parliamo di questo in
modo particolare abbiamo una pianta che
produce cibo
le mie amiche dove non solo visto che ha
parlato prima vegana lì Viene a nozze
sei lì Ciao vieni a nozze perché ogni
ettaro produce 8 10 quintali di
germoglio germoglio che è una roba da
matti non lo conosciamo bene perché non
c'è fresco in Italia arriva dalla Cina
Ma è tutto pieno di conservanti di robe
che non vanno bene in Italia comincia ad
esserci adesso Ma pensate al germoglio
del grano che è un filo e lo dico fa
benissimo fa bene questi sono germogli
di 7 etti otto etti un chilo cioè voglio
dire se li mangi dei campi 150 anni
perché Perché è pieno di aminoacidi è
pieno di vitamine è una roba davanti
Quindi produciamo cibo perché se no vai
a rubare il terreno alle pere alle mele
sapere 60-60 trattamenti chimici adesso
poi se mi mettono dopo sul video Mi
massacrano però lo stesso 60 trattamenti
chimici su una pera obbligatori se no
non vengono fuori qui non c'è chimica
zero zero chimica
40 tonnellate di legname per ettaro
17 tonnellate di assorbimento di CO2 per
ettaro e butta fuori ossigeno più di un
bosco normale diciamo di quelli che
conosciamo va bene del 35 per cento in
più perché è un sempreverde e butta
fuori anche d'inverno quando uscirà la
nebbia e tutte ste robe qui sto sforando
Allora ehm
per me va più veloce
[Applauso]
allora
gira giuro che faccio in fretta allora
io non mi fermo qua nel senso che non
sono sono abituato alle cose concrete
Questo è il nostro è il nostro robot vi
invito vi invito a partire dallo staff
di
il 17 sabato 17 al mattino due gruppi da
30 persone prima lo staff perché si
vogliono venire ovviamente e poi il
secondo giro se vi mettete d'accordo con
loro è un piacere Poi nel tempo se
qualcuno interessato a gruppi vi
facciamo vedere questa questa cosa
perché è bella questa crescendo stai già
due anni fra un anno tre quattro metri
in più cioè sono robe che crescono anche
un metro al giorno delle volte se ben
sei a posto
finisco Finisco per ruba un minuto
chiedo scusa dicevo che io non mi fermo
qua perché non mi basta
credo che
da questo palco da questo gruppo di
ragazzi da questa iniziativa e da questa
volontà si possa
fare una proposta non è una provocazione
è una proposta perché l'ambiente non ha
un colore politico non deve avere un
colore politico se noi ci cominciamo a
litigare sul fatto che è colpa dell'uomo
Oppure ho fatto strutturale continuiamo
a sbattere su una roba che non ci porta
da nessuna parte dato oggettivo che c'è
una crisi climatica che poi sia colpa
non sta a medirlo io ho le mie idee Ma
non è questo non ci si può dividere
politicamente su un tema così non ci si
può dividere Allora abbiamo una città
che ha una dimensione corretta c'è un
una volontà imprenditoriale ehm
strutturata
Qualcuno ha detto che
non sto facendo polemiche per qualcuno
ha detto che vuole fare mettere un
milione di alberi all'anno per i
prossimi cinque anni io credo che con
una volontà semplice semplice a patto
che siano d'accordo tutti è un impegno
mandare la prossima settimana o la
lettera a tutti i consiglieri comunali
del Comune di Ferrara tutti perché è
chiaro che ci deve essere una visione
unitaria Su questo tema e se viene
sostenuta Credetemi si fa per fare 100
ettari
di alberi o erba a crescita veloce non
c'è solo il bambù per fortuna così
almeno diranno ci sono alberi veri
100 ettari vuol dire 3 milioni di piante
dobbiamo provare a rovesciare da qui e
si può fare Credetemi si può fare se
abbiamo l'energia e la voglia di farlo
per invertire il meccanismo di mettere
del Verde dentro una città che va bene
Per l'amore del cielo si sta facendo
anche un bel lavoro in questa città ma
non basta dobbiamo mettere una città
dentro al verde una città dentro un
bosco
se noi la invertiamo questa cosa qui
Creiamo un meccanismo anche di
emulazione di interesse
pazzesco può partire qualcuno lo dirà
dopo perché l'ho sentita oggi nelle
prove che un gruppo di persone possono
fare Cose eccezionali da qui si può fare
si può fare in questa città e queste
Ferrara può essere l'esempio l'esempio
concreto da imitare per mettere 3
milioni di alberi intorno alla città in
dieci anni Abbiamo 3 milioni di alberi
intorno alla città la sostenibilità la
sostenuta tocca anche voi
[Applauso]